au mois d'août dernier l'aéroport de
kaboul étaient au centre de l'actualité
en effet des centaines de personnes le
prenais littéralement d'assaut afin de
trouver un vol pour s'échapper du pays
qu'en est il maintenant quelle
destination des sert-il c'est ce que
nous allons voir avant de reprendre une
activité normale les autorités ont
d'abord dû sécuriser le territoire de
l'aéroport et réparer ce qui pouvait
l'être juste avant leur départ les
américains ont largement dégradé les
infrastructures de l'aéroport le rendant
inutilisable il a donc fallu un certain
temps aux nouvelles autorités afin de
rendre les aéroports de nouveau
opérationnel
désormais l'activité passage et reprend
peu à peu des couleurs au gré des
accords politiques principalement avec
des pays voisins
il ya des vols vers le qatar les émirats
arabes unis à destination de dubaï vers
l'iran le pakistan et nous effectuons
des vols qui plomb matic vers la russie
le nombre de vols est différent selon
les jours c'est toujours différent
parfois il ya beaucoup de volants une
journée parfois peu leur général le dieu
merci elle a beaucoup de monuments
qu'ils y étaient loin de là
l'activité militaire reprend elle aussi
avec la remise en état progressive d'une
partie du matériel retrouvé sur place
derrière moi plusieurs dizaines
d'hélicoptères militaires américains
abandonnés ici par les troupes
américaines juste avant leur départ
alors justement avant leur départ et les
ont rendus inutilisables pour éviter
qu'il ne tombe dans les mains des
talibans mais peine perdue ces mêmes
talibans commence peu à peu à les
remettre en état de marche
un aéroport c'est aussi une activité de
fret et qui n'y ferais tu dis douane est
donc une source de devises non
négligeable pour les nouvelles autorités
vous savez on peut comparer les douanes
à tuyaux qui alimente l'état notre tuyau
sur le système étatique tous les revenus
vont à l'état tous nos postes de douane
servettaz tous les revenus vont dans le
budget de l'état
dans un pays enclavé comme les
l'afghanistan l'aéroport international
de kaboul est l'un des seuls liens avec
le reste du source de devises point
d'arrivée de voyageurs de fret et même
des d'humanitaires le nouveau pouvoir en
place a compris qu'avoir un aéroport
opérationnel était primordiale